master [ __ ] for KFC Konstantin Kotov Please
come through the
start-service company, which, as many people
know, has already bought the company grees Yes,
ladies and gentlemen, JVI Eliseeva, please clap the
company
details
Tatyana will start first let's
applaud please
Good morning dear guests Thank you
very much for joining us on this
very solemn day for us
which we have been waiting for so long Today we
will celebrate the grand opening
of our flagship Da
Rostikskaya restaurant this is really one of
our biggest e-  well, it’s
not a coincidence that it’s the chain of restaurants that
our new story to the Rostix brand begins with,
the restaurant with us has come a long way in
various transformations to the brand in 26 years
and we are very glad to welcome you here today
our corporate restaurants KFC
closed in March 22 now it is  66
restaurants that are actively
getting ready to open right from the
next few days and all this time we were
closed but our employees were with us
They continued to help work in our
partners
obligations on corporate
restaurants to our landlords and
partners And literally within the
next few days Yes, we
plan to open 25 restaurants in Moscow
15 restaurants in the
Khanty-Mansiysk Autonomous Okrug and
then we will open all of our remaining
26 restaurants in the Moscow region Yes
Within  May, therefore, very soon all our
restaurants will open their doors under the
Rostik brand and we will be ready to receive our
guests, this has become possible, but because
the transaction for the transfer of assets of our
company has been successfully completed
Today,
Univerest owns a network of corporate
restaurants, owns the rights to the
Rostix brand, and we continue to be the
master franchisor of the KFC brand. You know
that all our partner restaurants
have been working all this time and
are starting to work, but we certainly
have a
new interesting breakthrough task before us.
transition to a new brand and we believe in the
success of this transition because
we have a
very well-developed and I am sure
successful strategy.
Firstly, the transition to growth will allow us to
return to the development of our network.
As you know, we are the largest
restaurant chain in Russia  we have more than
10 almost 100 restaurants and the
transition to a new brand will allow us to
return to active growth, which
has always been the basis of our and a very important
component of our strategy, why else do
we believe in Success before this
strategy, and I am sure that today you
yourself will be able to  make sure of this because it is an
absolutely known fact that only in the
restaurants of our network the most delicious
chicken is found and the basis of a successful
arrival strategy is that the taste remains with
us Yes, our super taste the strength of our
product nothing changes These are the same
favorite products that please
our guests  you can try it yourself today
and see for yourself
the second very important component of our
successful strategy is our super service and
how we serve with what love
We welcome our guests
it is certainly every day our teams
provide such a wonderful service and
this is a
strong component of the strength of our brand
and  Olga will also be able to tell us in
more detail
and further development We believe in the
potential for
further growth in our country at
the moment, only half of the population of
our country has access to our
restaurants and our such a breakthrough goal is
to ensure that the whole country has
access and can try our
wonderful products  therefore, we believe
in strong growth and hope that
very, very soon we will be able to return to
this successful strategy We also
plan to fully maintain the
investments that we made in our
ecosystem from our suppliers from our
partners a-a we will maintain investments in our
digital ecosystem  in the development of the
brand Yes, and we will be able, so to speak, to
really actively continue to
develop the market
Well, probably the last point that I
wanted to note, which is
very important for us, since we said that
we are a company with a big heart within the framework
of this transaction, our fund will also be able to
open horizons to continue its
active work  and already this year we
were able to expand the support program for
our teenagers
from 51 regions to 55 regions and more than two
thousand wards of our foundation continue
to receive quality assistance and I
would also like to take the opportunity to
thank all our employees and
our franchise partners for and
all our guests who  support
our foundation and support and take an
active part in all volunteer
activities and in our networks which
are such an integral part
and a very important part of our work, well,
probably at this moment I wanted
to give the floor to Konstantin
[music]
Tatyana Thank you very much, really
such detailed information I  I am very glad
to welcome everyone such a large
number of press guests
glad to see that our countries Generates
interest I think that you have
looked at what changes
we have made here they
distinguish Our new brand from our
logo but we are for continuity We are for being
recognizable from-  in order for our
guests to enter our restaurant and feel
that they have come How to go home the most important thing is
taste the most important thing is food hospitality
but also the atmosphere that does not fall so that
it is preserved all the best that was in
growth Well, what we see here To me
I think it was a great job
to do It's a great design it's a great
atmosphere that we were able to achieve
I'll tell you a little about myself maybe
because we're people a little bit
New here But we're not new in this
business We are one of the oldest
partners and once really our own
business  We started with Rostix, the one
that was once again on the air, it was 15
years ago, and after the sale of this network to
ambrands, we switched so smoothly
together with partners who started this
business of the Russian Federation years ago, we
crossed all the plugs and developed within the framework of the
KFC development standards at  we have 41
restaurants in 4 regions, and when
an offer was received to participate in
this big deal, the
acquisition of the entire existing
chain, including franchise restaurants, we,
of course, responded with pleasure with
our partner of
fragments Andrey I am my partner of the
Smart service company who won the
process itself And now we  signed a deal
yambrets and acquired one hundred percent of the share of the
rice company, respectively, what
Tatyana said, this is all included in this
wonderful company and the most pleasant of course,
and the fact that we would like to
inherit this team is the people who
built it all the people who have achieved
success for the pit business in Russia  who
have shown the best results and
have been recognized many times as the best team both in
Europe and in the world, and these are empty words
because it practically did not show such a pace as KFC in Russia
in the world, we
hope that we can resume this pace
now we have skills we have
expertise  resources there are people who
know how to do there are partners who have
their own development territories 22 partners
who would like to continue development
within the Rostik family now
we can’t open brush restaurants, but we are
obliged to support, therefore this is a very
important focus in order to maintain
all standards, but development and  A new
story We hope to develop it under the
Rostics brand. Here are probably
some of the most important things I announced.
Briefly, then I think that there will be an
opportunity for your questions.
Our main idea is that we should
now pick up this brand and develop it. Well, we
certainly could together with the team  Who
represents
the operating Tatyana
CEO and colleagues who are standing around
are all who took part in the creation of
this brand I hope that we
will be able to continue to support it,
develop it and bring it to a new, correct
quality Russian level Thank you
restaurant because the restaurant team is looking
forward to when we  we will open
when we start serving guests and for
us it is really a joy and believe
me I have not the slightest
doubt that it will be successful
because the formula for success is very simple it is the
taste of the product is the experience of the guests and everything
we have done with our team already
for many years we have always focused on the
taste of the product Now I tell you as the
COO with all my heart I
say I guarantee that the taste of the product
will remain unchanged And the most important thing that
we want to bring is service We want
our employees our hostesses to
see today what beautiful
hostesses we have  so that they have Honey eyes and
that they give you joy happiness and
that Bring a guest to a restaurant he
has warmth kindness joy
Because people buy emotions and in
our today's world we need these
emotions we need warmth and our super service
will give this warmth and the most  the main thing is the
taste of the product. What is our
pride is our passion and
love, and those of you who go on a
tour of the kitchen today will see it so that
we really love what we do
and are proud of our product and the most
important thing in all this is Our employees
Our employees  whom we value, we love, we
develop and create conditions so
that it is not a job, so that it is
their home in which they are really loved,
which they are warmly Joyful and such
employees only happy employees
can give happiness to a guest, therefore
Our first priority is to
give and make it so happy
employees of our restaurants and Trust
me that we care about them We love them
we appreciate them and today I think you will
see it too that we have the best
employees and we will continue to
focus on the taste of the product to the
level of service We have a special
program that we  with the guys now we are
going through this super service And super service
what does it mean to go further and more
promises than the guest expects the employee in the
restaurant is a magician who can
give magical moments of happiness to
each guest in the restaurant and we teach how to
do it And of course we will
carefully and carefully listen to the feedback
the connection of our guests because
it works for us every complaint is a
gift and we accept this gift in
order to be better and of course I can
talk endlessly Because
I love what I do I love this
brand I love this team But the most
important thing is that
Faith in Success that it will be such a
great team that we
have this is our support office and a team of
restaurants we will succeed and the chicken
will be delicious and the service will be impeccable
welcome to our restaurants we
will be glad to see you with us Thank you
very much for this  warm It seems to me,
but now I’m paying attention to
your friends’ questions, therefore, a big request
to introduce yourself
Hello Christina Moscow 24 Tell me
about
the company’s signature dish spicy wings
Tell me if you managed to repeat the recipe or
make it on the skin
I will answer your question
more fully all the recipes in our menu are saved
completely everything And if you pass now
Look at that Technology And
the dishes that we cook They
completely repeat me KFC is a big
plus because as part of our
agreement with Jan Brand we
support two franchises with the same
recipes so you I hope you can’t
distinguish the taste at all Well maybe  the hands
were different But the recipes are always the
same so the wings will be just as sharp
Nika Nikolai Russia 24 Please tell
us in more detail about the plans to
expand the network about the timing and exits to many
regions
Now our main goal is to
rebrand we have a plan to finish the whole
country in  18 months Hopefully more
ambitious Well maybe We'll do it in
Maybe a little over a year there so the
main focus now is to
bring the chains
to Rostix we're negotiating with
partners this requires a physical
rebuild of the interior exterior from the
honey training teams
now we have expansion plans for
about new regions at the moment
there is no this question
Today, therefore, press conferences also
today about the expansion that
was earlier in a couple of plans that were
approved by Wuxi, before we had a large
number of partner locations that
wanted to expand, I hope they will be
implemented within the framework,
but I think that  we have to increase the
same pace as Tatyana was talking about, we have
the potential for about 1000 locations and the
main focus is the cities that
are located today Well, not the attention of big
brands That is, these are cities with 100,000 below
the population
I wanted to ask a question why
the English name Rostics was chosen  not
a Russian, now there is a lot of
connection with this, various disputes, even this
week a certain community of the Ostankino
district of Moscow wrote denunciations about
restaurants with English names.
Only this option is possible, or is it
still in Russian, and why
is this?
Probably, I will try to answer But
in-  the first as Konstantin explained Yes,
for continuity we have been
building the KFC brand very successfully for 13 years,
this brand that loves our guests and
as part of the transition in growth to us, it is important,
among other things, to maintain some kind of continuity
and
approaching the issue of rebranding as
part of the deal, we are on  in fact, we
prepared very well Yes, we conducted
surveys of our guests to test the
spelling of different names and now the
Latin name won Yes, this is what
our guests voted for ah and uh, we
heard it and we are implementing it Yes, it is clear
that if there are any other changes
trends the
rights to the Rostics brand in all
spellings with all letters, so to speak, they
belong to us during the registration process and we will be able to
flexibly approach this
issue if necessary, but it seems to us that this is how the
visual range of the brand is formed now,
its new identity is on the one
hand  as if it has some kind of
continuity up to the stripes black and white
outline red black and white colors here is
such an
original writing and on the other
hand this is enough I
want to say
enough it carries some new
challenge some new energy Yes, which we
plan to put into
practice and more actively, so to speak
to approach the solution of different issues Yes and
develop Yes quite confidently I
want to speak aggressively but I also want to
say yes and aggressively at the same time
because we
really have big plans big
ambitions We believe
Thank you very much I
wanted to ask you all the same directly I
think all journalists  I’m
still interested in what, in addition to the signboard, will change in
Rostix, there may be some new dishes
or some names will still go away,
some new ones will come Here’s what exactly
will change, that is, in addition to the signage, it will
probably change again, I’ll pick up, that
is, the identica KFC brand, of course
will not be present in growth yes, that is, the
brand brand identifiers they will change
inside the restaurant everything to Rostics Yes, uh,
very
beautiful original spicy ones are added Yes,
for example, such wonderful chickens,
from the point of view of the menu, now at the stage of
restoring the work of corporate
restaurants, the menu will be  the same
really two
such
iconic KFC names in growth
will be replaced, yes, that is, the boxmaster will
become the height, the master of taking away will become the
chef roll all the rest, but at the same time,
the taste of these products will be exactly
the same cooking technologies are the
same, yes, that is,
only the name of the two products all
other products will change  recipes Yes, and the
price menu is all the same as now You
can see more than a thousand
working in KFC restaurants will be in
our Rostics restaurants Of course, we
never stand still outside the
KFC network, especially not within the
Rostik network, we will work on  innovations
on the expansion of the product line on the
introduction of new products,
not only product innovations, but also
technological innovations, as it were, new formats, and
of course we hope that very soon we
will be able to please
our guests with new products, including Yes, our guests are now at the
stage of restoring work and at the stage of the
first wave
the difference in the menu
Thank you Tatyana So we have a lot of questions
quietly
the name is familiar to Russians from
the 2000s Tell me why they kept
the name and didn’t come up with it Let’s say something
new Thank you Let’s
probably answer because I
started in Rostik and indeed this
brand was remembered by a lot of Russians by
the research we conducted
before choosing a name, more than 20%, in
general, in Russia they recognize this
trademark And in the cities I was present
there more than 40% of people Well Siberia Moscow there
our regions remember the so-called
moreover such a connotation of spelling with the
word Ross it is, in principle, very
runs well and people's attitudes
were very positive towards growth,
moreover, the writing is either in Latin or in
Cyrillic It's still not quite an
English word, it's something of ours, it's sonorous
in the middle
Youth is quite a
challenge With a little such
business aggression and it seemed to us that  this
name fits very well into the theme of
our future projects, so it
was chosen Well, I don’t want any
special analogies, but it seems to us that
it is sonorous, simple, understandable and well
remembered
Thank you girl nearby and Then we will come up with
a word with history
Here is the first option on it was  a
chicken is shown why in the end it was
decided to abandon it and immediately the second
question How marketing communications will change
Well, in fact, not that the chicken was
the first option, we had a lot of
options of mine tested,
created, creative, tried
to receive feedback, as a result,
we settled on that logo  and volume of
writing which, it seems to us,
performs strategically. Our task is,
first of all, a sense of
continuity and, at the same time, the creation of
such a really novelty when
introducing new energy or something. Yes,
because the brand will develop and it
seems to us that the current version fully
corresponds to this more successfully.
you saw how the chicken is what
leaked to the network, we did not declare it as
our brand, so there were many other
various attempts and interesting projects,
the chicken looked like a fireman, for example, the
rooster was the chicken, we have preserved
this is our passion heart this is our heart
that we give to our guest  our guest is
therefore super service and here is the heart our
chicken is what you and the guys say
is what we want to convey to our
guests but this is not a logo this is how
we see it
then with what warmth and
passion we bring this product to
our
guests
Thank you, we
haven’t gone far yet
Thank you
Hello, I worked as an independent specialist
once again at MTS Trans and I remember this
rebranding and in general, first of all, I
want to say my opinion that Rostik
is right for me  I like the name very much,
so I wanted to ask about the design
because it is somehow such a distinctive
feature of yours and your dentition and logos and
fonts I wanted to clarify some of you,
maybe you used contract services,
or you created it all on your own
-the story of this
may be like a couple of words literally
look at what you see in this
restaurant Yes, and look at our strategies,
for example,
we plan to do this even
without closing the restaurant, because
only the identica brand is changing, everything
else is very complex Yes, this and
furniture, the arrangement of tables there and inside
Yes, and the ceiling design elements This is a very
complicated complex process, and
of course it is clear overnight that this
cannot be changed And this will not change this is
what we are proud of this is how we
developed within the KFC brand according to the
standards of the KFC brand  I use, as it were,
including global developments,
ideas, and so on, and always global
developments, they have adapted for our
local markets Yes, because we have always
tested checking what the
news likes, how convenient
How to correlate there I don’t know the number of
transaction seats and so on
quite complicated, say  process And
of course, it has
evolved over the 13 years that KFC has been developing, and at the moment we have
several design concepts that you
can see in our restaurants and this
process of evolution will continue But
now at the transition stage it will not be the
Revolution of the
Rostics brand As you can see it
it fits very organically yes,
this, among other things,
ensures continuity in that restaurant KFC And then,
of course, like any chain, any
concept, we will continue to develop
you will have such an opportunity Yes,
and probably here, too, I will pick up this
point of view
strategically nothing changes Yes,
success is our scale  the fact that we have
so many restaurants we are loved by guests
it is certainly accessible
we are
accessible a highly traditional brand we
need to serve a large number of
guests and this is only possible when
we remain accessible and this part of the
strategy is
unambiguously preserved  important
work with our suppliers with our
partners is a whole ecosystem that
unites around our thousands of
restaurants and very many
local suppliers, including Yes, and
we are certainly always working on
optimization in order to
remain as accessible as possible plus
we work in a very competitive environment
We have avery
serious competitors in the market, we
respect your strategy,
so nothing changes here and we
will continue to be available
to our guests and the good news is that
all the coupons everyone loved
770 it remains on the menu all the coupons all the
programs that we had they all
will be all  we have a loyalty program
excellent Thank you very much here there are
three more questions that took the queue
so let's slowly
move forward
Hello NTV channel My name is
fantima business news please tell
me what market share you
plan to occupy And the second question besides
the Russians there were some other options How to
name
look at the market share we are generally very
ambitious
companies Yes, once we always said
that we want to be the number one brand
now we have succeeded in terms of the
number of restaurants we really are the
number one brand but now this is
not enough for us as if yes and we want to be  the
number one brand in terms of market share Yes,
therefore, we have such an ambitious goal for
ourselves We set ourselves to achieve it, as it were,
through expansion Yes, that is, by
opening a larger restaurant The number of
restaurants and by unconditionally expanding
the frequency of visits Yes and
the number of transactions Therefore, Yes
We have an ambitious goal  about
market share and we want to be the leader
now we are sure number two but we are
sure that our strategy of course is
not in one year but we are developing a
strategy How do we get to
market leadership leaders
let me remind you that when KFC from retail it
was less than 10 percent Today  we
occupy more than 30 percent this is a very
big step there in a fairly short
amount of time restaurants were built
very actively here our main message is
consolidation with partners and expansion into
the depths of the country certainly all
modern technological platforms and
our ecosystems will allow us an
egoistic loyalty club here and the
Club and  our regular guests, all the
work will continue,
I’ll say that
Rostik once KFC bought Rostik, and in
fact, at the stage of the transaction, both brands
belonged to the same copyright holder Yes, and
take drostiks This deal was such a
manageable one, it was transferred as if to us And
now we are his  It is
this controlled transition that
actually allowed us to keep the copyright holder That is,
it is not something new, as it were, having no
history where there can be doubt Yes,
will you keep me, will we keep the taste,
etc.
including
the right holder to be sure that we
will preserve the taste of the product Yes, and therefore all
the recipes of the technology all the skills that
we had and have within the framework of the
KFC master franchise, we are
allowed to say so yes This is how to continue to
successfully use and provide That is
exactly the success of the strategy yes to save
Brandy Rostix therefore  there are probably
serious alternatives to something like this, yes,
some new name is weighing on the scales there, something completely
new Yes, but at the same time how to ensure
continuity And what will happen to the product,
probably no other strategy
could somehow compete with this
therefore, there were probably no serious alternatives.
therefore, we can
say today that we are
just explaining Actually how
all these issues look like in Russia now because it’s
a little bit
out how many franchisees And how much
your own management and most importantly do
you plan to keep it as it is or
will you take more in your own
management or or what  you won’t
be there yet Yes, well, but then I’ll
roughly explain what we acquired is a
100% share of the company spawning
inside there is not sharply a master KFC franchise
and a franchise that belongs to the
property as a trademark
also within the company 66 restaurants
owned by it on the right of
ownership somewhere where  - something for rent that
is operated directly by the company
as a whole in the country now there are
1.250 plus or minus restaurants Because
something is constantly opening and closing,
but the figure is of the order of such a
Smart service company, we, as buyers,
were franchisees one of the 22 franchisees in the
Russian Federation We operate in the
regions of the Udmurt Republic Perm
region Kirov region Tatarstan We
ourselves have 41 restaurants of our own, but
now there will also be 42 tomorrow we will open
another track,
so now we have
66 + 42 and 180 restaurants together with Everest,
the rest of the restaurants belong to
independent partners who are
members of the franchise you said
Rostik network Because now the
vast majority of such Syrians Our
task is to encourage our partners
to move to Rostik, since we see that
development plans and development opportunities
are possible only with growth, this is not because
people who want to stay in KFC
within the framework of legal obligations, we
will be one hundred of them  percent to support in the same way
as they supported before that
Therefore, KFC as a brand will live to
work, it will not work to develop, but it will not
work with success and the whole service, and the fact
that Olga told you there is nothing
like two children, you always
pay attention early, so there ca
n’t be any  there should be other approaches.
In addition, so that we can make
relations absolutely evenly and blood and all partners.
Thank you. And another question was to talk a lot
about plans for the development of unmarriage.
Tatyana, are you planning to go abroad?
Federation and we are not planning to
leave the Russian Federation
Thank you so here
you can imagine what news
about the quality of products will remain those
suppliers that were earlier and the
suppliers are all Russian and the
second question about drinks after I
understand that
you stopped cooperating there for some
time medical head  now there is some kind of
new supplier, that is, who will be the
main supplier as regards the
quality of work with
suppliers, we continue to work as
finish suppliers
suppliers
99%, yes Russian suppliers And the most
important product that is there the
heart of our product is
our chicken, all
suppliers continue to work  with us and everything
related to this was difficult with Pepsi it
was difficult for us before Chernogolovka we
went through all this and today you can already
try all the new drinks we
have we work we continue to work with
pepsi We work in the
range of drinks that they give us
syrups  can supply
now not in rostex or some
such positions that used to be
abandoned but now KFC is coming It seems to me there
is no need to return anything
old Yes And if you notice This is not
the same old brand Rostics after all We have been the
main love of our guests for 13 years  Yes to the
KFC brand and this is the new base on
which we will build the cane brand there
is no need to return
anything old We are working on new
proposals they will definitely
new ones will be tastier as it were and more
qualitatively more interesting
therefore there
will definitely be new ones Yes but we are not
looking back we  we have a
team that is developing
new products and they already have a large
line of products by the end of the year we already know a
lot of products there will be new products
will be the most important thing for the
guest
x
we ​​have this task worth it we will
do it
Thank you
Let's review How much  more questions
about to roughly understand yes
one question there and the final one
here hello
Thank you very much
and secondly you said about the
loyalty program it’s very interesting for us here Chicken
Club please tell us about the conditions of the
program Well, in general, what I heard for the first time
in the fast food loyalty program
Here, please, thank you, the
loyalty program is something Well, it’s not new, but it takes
a very long time to tell in the program, but
Probably the best Well, within the
time frame, you need to become a member of this
loyalty program and see, but we are
very
kind to the guests who
visit us constantly  restaurants and
details - It will be possible to see this program exactly
when to become subscribed
and become a member of this loyalty program
download our application and join the
program our loyalty girl
actually had a question she stretched her arms a lot
Daria Andrianova
there was information that several
KFC franchises applied to
government commission with a request to
suspend the transaction Tell me
if this conflict has been resolved and we are conducting
a dialogue with this thank you well
government commissions we have answered
all questions in an exhaustive way
received full agreement Yes, as you can
see the transaction is completed all permissions
have been received therefore all
the calls indicated by the partners for all questions  Yes, an
exhaustive answer was given, and
of course, this work on
rebranding partner companies,
we still have to do this task,
which we will now take on,
but we believe in its success and every day with
each opening of our corporate
restaurant in Rostik with the opening of
Konstantin's restaurants  Yes, there will be more
confidence and facts in its territories Yes,
of course, there will be more and we are absolutely
sure that partners Yes, having
really seen that
Our guests will
come to Rostik KFC restaurants with the same love,
we will be able to provide this
accelerated transition strategy that will allow
our partners to  to develop
in the future.
Let me add a little to your question.
I met with all the people who
wrote this appeal, we spoke and I
can clearly say that each
of them was heard and there was no conflict.
It was just
people's concern for the development of their business, this is
normal. Because  that people do not understand
what is happening because not all the
information was available, they
were somewhat agitated,
so now it seems to me that the situation is
completely open. It is clear that all the information has
already been communicated to everyone and
today we do not experience any difficulties in
any communication, it seems that
people understand everything perfectly.
presentations of the information
that was conveyed, so today we are
determined that you move positively together
Thank you Yes, we literally take three more questions Yes,
from this side
Please tell us
marketing communications after
No we will keep the entire volume of marketing
investments we will continue this active
interesting competition that is
now  is happening and
definitely, as if we had a
long-term deal, we must increase
the volume of investments, therefore, it will
only change in the direction of strengthening Yes, and there
will be news there will be new companies
very interesting strategies, but definitely the
volume of investments and the volume of marketing
support will remain and continue to
grow
Thank you
Ivan sample me Konstantin  question in
continuation of the
story of the franchisee You said that we are
waiting for the reprinting of restaurants, it
turns out about 60 corporate and
40 of yours,
and you said that everything is in order with the franchisee As a
result, even though I understand the deal
now formally, I just finished it,
but anyway you are talking to them  do
you have any understanding of which part of
them have already told you for sure that they
will come to visit,
I can say now an agreement has been reached
on the transfer of 2/3 of the system of
delicious restaurants
regions, this means they call surnames
the same as calling regions Here, but I
will say that the next two months there will be
a large amount of new information there. I
think that you will have a lot of
exhaustive new data, but literally
I think that the next one will be some kind of
more or less clear vision of what  cities and
Which regions do you cross first But
this will be a serious country Therefore,
we will have many grand openings
in cities with a population of over a million and other important
cities for us in general with partners a
constructive constructive conversation is being
discussed rather whether it is
necessary or not necessary how to do it
speed and in
stages  What is more important to launch in advance
And you can understand that 700 before the end of the year,
but in fact, speed is so
important here because it is important to close it as soon as possible
so that within one city or one
trading zone does not create competition
between brands, after all, we manage
standard brands and Our joint
policy  is that a person
does not create ambivalent visions that
there is some kind of competition between Russia,
therefore we are trying to competently separate
these two processes Today I can say
there is an official opening here and for
example in Izhevsk there the city will be closed
quite quickly a small
further the next region
in Moscow for more such a more
difficult  but nevertheless, we
would like to ask a special
KFC recipe that contains 11 herbs and
spices that are said to be stored by
several people, whether it was passed on to you by
inheritance
Well, as you have repeatedly
said until today that the taste of the product
remains the same
secret recipes because they store
several  man, we do not have
rostex, but the suppliers who provide us with
the right spices, all suppliers
will continue to work with us, so the taste of the
product remains the same Thank you very much
Friends, let's
applaud the speaker, please
stand
the question
so a little later after the official
opening ceremony Yes, it will be possible to ask
Konstantin personally a question  take the
approach yes And now we will make a short
pause for 5-7 so that ah
Dear cameraman Yes, we managed to set up the
camera and literally in 5 minutes
invited everyone to the cashier area where the
official opening ceremony will take place
and cutting the ribbon
part is possible
and the most delicious part Friends promised